Any communications, whether it's a website
or a video or even a circus, requires knowing
your audience and adjusting the presentation to
them. For instance, you're doing a circus, it's
for kids, of course you're going to go full-on
Ringling Brothers with lions and tigers and bears
and clowns. But if you have a more sophisticated
audience, you might have a little more nuance
and artistry. A little more Cirque Du Soleil than
Ringling Brothers. What do we need to know about
our audience for visualization? It's really
the same as for any communications challenge.
We need to understand their culture, their
level of expertise, and a few other things.
First, culture. Your audience comes from a certain
place in the world. It affects their language,
it affects their perspective, it affects their
context, so many different things. For example,
think about, what does a wedding look like?
Sometimes it looks like this or like this or
like this. It affects the colors that are used.
Color theory's its own big conversation that we're
not going to cover in detail in this course,
but culture's an important influence on color
amongst other things. For instance, what does a
wedding dress look like? Is it white? Is it red?
And remember that, what looks odd in one culture
might be completely normal in another one.
Another thing culture influences is narrative
context. Does your audience know the underlying
story of what you're talking about? For instance,
let's say you're creating a visualization of Wayne
Gretzky statistics. Wayne Gretzky was probably
the greatest hockey player who ever lived.
If you're doing this visualization for people
in northern countries who play a lot of hockey,
you probably don't need to set a lot of context.
You don't need to explain who Wayne Gretzky is.
But, if it's a visualization for people in,
maybe, Brazil or Madagascar, they might not
have as much of that context. You might need to
set up the story a little bit better for them.
The next one is level of expertise. If you're
creating a project and it's for people who are
experts in an industry, you're going to approach
it in one way. Less context, less hand-holding,
maybe even use different language, different
types of words, more lingo. If your audience
isn't quite as informed on the subject, you're
going to provide more background information,
more hand-holding. It's going to be like,
maybe, a shallower story with less detail.
There's also what it is called the
consumption context or channel.
Your work isn't just for fun or self-admiration,
you want to publish something somewhere somehow.
So, whether you're creating a visualization for
the New York Times or the Daily Show or a Bill's
Blog for data dorks, it's going to change
your approach. One might be more serious.
Maybe a higher standard of excellence,
maybe more statistical integrity.
The other might be more irreverent. You
might have lower journalistic standards.
You might round to fewer decimal
places with your numbers.
It's not about being less accurate, but you may
be less detail-oriented in certain contexts.
Another issue is accessibility. Data
visualization is all about visualization,
it's all about the eye. We're only
dealing with sighted people, correct?
Well, yes and no. You could say that you could
create a, quote, unquote, data visualization
for the blinds, but really it's just audio. Maybe
there are other ways of thinking about this field.
But there are other accessibility issues also,
even if you don't go quite that far, the big one
being colorblindness. From one to 3% of people are
colorblind, and there's an especially common form
called red-green colorblindness where people have
difficulty distinguishing between red and green.
Just think about stock market charts where red
is always used to mean prices going down and
green for prices going up. Think about what that
might mean for the one to 3% of people who have
trouble distinguishing between those two colors.
Luckily, in trying to channel your audience
and understand what they're going through,
there's a great website to help you with this.
There's this website where you can
actually take an image and upload it.
You can select an image from your hard drive, and
it's going to show you what the chart looks like.
This is the original image over here. And then
you can actually go in and click on these little
radio buttons and see what it would look like for
people with different forms of colorblindness.
It can help you channel your audience and see
what they would see. It's a great way to take a
look at your work and test it and make sure that
you're being friendly to all of your audience.
There are other things to think about when
you're thinking about the visually impaired.
A big one being contrast and font size, creating
your charts with enough contrast to be easily
seen, making sure the font size is large enough
to be read. Forget about visual impairment,
just think about your audience. If they tend
to be over 40 years old, make sure your font
sizes aren't 10-point. If your chart is for
college kids, don't worry about it so much.
The next thing to keep in mind is whether or
not your audience consists of true believers or
skeptics, or more often than not, it's both, but
you have to be aware of it. If you're visualizing
data, let's say, about climate change, to
climate scientists, it'll be received differently
than if you're sharing the same data with a
publication targeting the coal mining industry.
This is a dangerous lesson in that you don't want
to overthink how much convincing you need to do,
otherwise it might bias what you share and how
you frame it. On the other hand, being aware of
whether you're sharing information to change
minds or simply to provide the truth, is good
to understand, because it might affect how deeply
you dive and how much interactivity you provide.
And finally, there is the action that you want
your audience to take. You're sharing your content
for an action, a reaction from your audience.
You need to know what you're looking for,
what action you're looking for to design better
outcomes. Do you want someone to call their
congressman after looking at your visualization?
Do you want them to answer a poll question? Do you
want them to share it on social? Do you want to
inspire them in some other way? If you constantly
ask yourself if your design is leading toward
this outcome, you're more likely to achieve it.
These are all the things you have to understand
about your audience when you're creating
visualizations for them, but it's more than that.
It's not just about understanding, it's about
channeling them. It's about really getting inside
their head. You don't want to ignore their culture
and accessibility issues and all these other
things, you want to actually feel their pain.
You want to understand it as though you are them.
You'll be less likely to be influenced by bias,
for instance because you're going to feel
their skepticism, their arguments against
what you're showing them. It's going to help you
articulate more clearly and factually if you can
really imagine being them. Imagine that you are
them and you'll communicate more meaningfully.